in this lesson we're going to talk about
proportions so proportions is definitely
something they test you on on the s80 so
let's go through it here and we'll do
some example problems so first of all
you know what is the proportion well
basically a proportion is a ratio equal
to another ratio so for example here we
have two thirds is equal to x over nine
medias way to solve this problem is to
cross multiply and solve the other way
to do it is you can say well 3 times 3
is 9 so therefore 2 times 3 would be six
but I think for most students they would
just use this method of cross
multiplying 3 times X is 3 x 2 times 9
is 18 divide everything by 3 and you can
see that X is equal to 6 now another
problem that comes up on you know with
regards to proportions is where you have
like a map or a scale and they'll say
like you know one inch is equal to 12
feet okay so what you can do is you can
make a proportion like this you can say
the scale to actual or real life is
equal to the scale to real life so for
example if 1 inch equals 12 feet find
your map it's 3 inches that's going to
be equal to X feet you can set up a
proportion solve for that missing
quantity right okay and then the last
thing I want to talk about here before
games and examples of the properties of
proportion so let's just assume that any
over B equals C over D is a true
proportion meaning that these two ratios
are equal well what you can do with
these proportions is you can interchange
these quantities on the diagonal so I
could put see here and be here so that's
what I did in the second example you
could also switch them on this diagonal
you could put D here and a there so you
could switch them you can take the
reciprocal of both sides so you could
say be over a is equal to D over C okay
and then this last one which tends to
confuse students a little bit I just
want to explain a little bit more here
is that see how I over B equals C over D
that's our original proportion but then
they're adding this be here it looks
like they're adding the denominator to
the numerator b over b is actually equal
to 1 so they're adding one to the left
side you see here look like they're
adding the demand
you're to the numerator so that's D over
D which is one to the right side if you
add one to both sides of the equation
it's still equivalent so this is just
another property for proportions it's
oftentimes overlooked it's just it looks
like you're adding the denominator in
the numerator but you really just like
adding one to both sides of the equation
so you want to keep it balanced so let's
go through a couple examples example one
says if a turtle breathe three breath
every two minutes how many breaths does
it take in one day so pause the video
see if you can do this one on your own
and we'll go through it together so the
way I would approach this is you know
it's taking three breaths for every two
minutes so I'm just going to say three
brass for every two minutes equals how
many breaths will express is one day now
see how we're working with minutes so we
need to convert 24 hours okay yes a day
and the minutes right well we know that
there's you know 24 hours in a day and
we know that there's 60 minutes for
every one hour so here you can see 24 x
60 would give us the number of minutes
so let's see what that comes out to real
quick here so we've got 24 x 60 which is
1440 1440 so now only cross multiply we
can solve for x you've got two times x
equals three x 1440 divide both sides by
2 and X should come out to let's see
times 3/2 2160 breaths in one day for
the turtle okay so here with me so far
so basically we're just setting up a
ratio equal to a ratio and we're solving
okay now for example 2 it says if X
divided by y equals 2/5 which also must
be true and they give us four options
here so go ahead and pause the video and
see if you can figure out which one of
these is true okay so what I would do is
let's just analyze them one by one so
you see it action / why they flipped it
there y over X right they took the
reciprocal but if they flip this side
they should flip this guy as well this
should equal to 5 over 2 so that's not
right okay let's go to the exam step be
so X divided by two you can see what
they did here is they replace Y with 2
so this should relieve you y over five
because remember we talked about how you
can interchange it on the diagonal right
but that's not right so x divided by two
should really equal Y divided by five so
they have that reverse so be as Matt it
okay now let's look at letter C so let
us see it looks like what they're doing
here is they've got x + 5 / y equals to
0 or 5 so it looks like see two fifths
nothing is really changing here they're
just adding this 5 to the numerator this
isn't this is not true you just can't
add one thing to one side of the
equation and not add it to the other
side to keep it balanced right so it has
to be letter D but let's analyze a
little bit further notice that you know
what they're doing here is we have x
divided by Y that's the original
fraction we have here original issuing
up here minus y / y so what they're
doing is they're subtracting 1 from this
side so if you subtract 1 from this side
to 5th minus 1 is negative three-fifths
or they're keeping that equation
balanced they're just subtracting 1 from
both sides so the dusting sir here is
going to be letter D so again think
about you know what proportion is and
how to solve it and also you know pay
attention to these properties of
proportions and we use the lesson if you
need to otherwise i'll see you in the
next lesson